do I regret any part of that experience
all these years later you know it's hard
for ya sure the writer you regret how
long it takes you to fully figure out
what the real situation was and I want
to rewrite it in my head and know the
whole thing home rather than only part
of it
so I think I it's hard to find fault
though I mean regret really means what
does regret mean it's not like I wasn't
trying very hard to do my best some of
these things just have to play out the
way they play out
yeah I'd never really had any problem
with that
it was a that was probably not a great
fit you know the world kind of divides
into people of one opinion of Oprah
Winfrey and people who have kind of the
diametrically opposite opinion and
that's a remarkable thing to achieve to
divide the world too they're sort of
parting the seeds I think I feel some
confidence she'd be comfortable with the
magnitude of that image